I literally can't think of a better way
to start the next 100 episodes of daily
be than this amazing email from Andre
and using his entire mashup video as
episode 1001 as a recap of where we
together have gotten in the last hundred
episodes on to another 100 episodes my
friends before I go into this by show of
hands how many people here have no idea
who I am or anything about my spiel tell
the truth raise them that [ __ ] hurts
I get thousands of emails a week how do
I find my passion and literally I apply
a go I would tell you my punch line is
what would you do if you could just do
it all the time take everybody a lot
happiest then they get to do what they
wanted me to thank you when you got to
believe it you want to do you one that
is the seductive nature of
entrepreneurship it was 70 but there's a
problem
there's a naivete in the world that just
cuz you talk people are gonna listen
you actually have been good how do you
stay living I'm gonna ask you question
how don't you stay you won the lotto of
the universe which is you are a human
being on earth and you're not driven and
you're not fired up and you're willing
to sit like a lump and just wait till
you die you suck
I don't know what everybody like you're
gonna be 90 and you're gonna look back
and what this is it I mean there's just
so much complaining there's so much
cynicism there's so much you got lucky
there's so much for everybody just want
to point that other people put your
[ __ ] self at the end of the day it's
gonna be what its gonna be
it all comes down to 20 30 40 years from
now
like what it's just results how do
people around you feel about you how
much did you create what impact did you
have on people it's the money it's the
same it's actually impacting patta on
people it's the way your family thinks
about you it's the way your best friends
think about you you can be a [ __ ]
loser
entrepreneur and this you can be an
awesome person and give back to society
you can book if you've got a talent if
you're good enough if you are good
enough to be up here to make me bling if
you are good enough nobody's stopping
you not [ __ ] Donald Trump not the
[ __ ] Russians or nobody if you are a
minority if you are a female if you are
transgender if you're a [ __ ] alien
the market doesn't give a [ __ ]
it makes best [ __ ] you win
if anybody has ever made that looks like
you can you come here and what's harder
much harder than getting money or
respect from the establishment is
actually winning at the market when when
somebody will say to me well Gary I
can't get funding because I'm a girl but
I can't get funding because I'm from
Mexico bro it's way harder to actually
have your product again with customers
then to get some old white dudes on Sand
Hill Road to write you a check so if
this is breaking you down if you're
crying now you're in deep [ __ ] [ __ ]
the market makes old white dudes that
are racist see some breakfast something
to happen your campus visualizing this
isn't a secret [ __ ] everybody should
live their lives the way they want to
but if you want to build something big
if you want to create a big business
hard work is the first second and third
part of your formulas when you learn the
audacity to be an entrepreneur and own
your own business and go on all the
riches and great things that come with
it you need to put in the work I promise
you if you look at your eight hours
every day two to three of them you're
spending on dumb [ __ ]
work is the variable of success work you
don't know a single person on earth
that's successful that didn't put in
work nobody watching this right now
nobody watching this right now knows a
single person that became successful
without the work you know what I feel I
feel an epic rant I feel like I have to
do a [ __ ] grant so I'm in good
spirits we'll see what happens today
if you work in a job you are not an
entrepreneur now I know that hurts I'm
gonna say it again if you are now as
you're running through the airport we're
driving on the highway or going to a job
you my friend are not an entrepreneur
like you can't just decide you're gonna
be an entrepreneur we can there's a big
difference between being an entrepreneur
and having entrepreneurial tendencies
and actually being successful
entrepreneurs punchline is this way too
many people are playing it either do it
we're dead
there is no in-betweens this is binary
anything was proved that they were 15 16
to a day you thought they were
hyperbolized and they were eight or nine
you never liked every minute something's
you didn't realize that it's every day
always forever then you're playing a
different game
you got a lesson with the [ __ ] that
comes along with it super funny if I can
be a bunch of 4:21 and play the game if
you [ __ ] lose you
[Music]
who put you down
recognize that you can attack the world
in a totally different way if you were
lucky enough to be born during this era
every time there is an actual abstention
revolution enormous money is made and
enormous money is nice just because we
weren't first doesn't mean you can't be
best when you're dealing with something
get [ __ ] done we need to go back
I can tell you what to do my screwdriver
works but if you don't go and do it then
that screwdrivers suck [ __ ]
a lot of people look at finished
products they look at the Brawn today
then look at Cody today they look at
Beyonce today if I'm sitting on a couch
and I'm like oh that athlete thinks
you're so fancy I was in there for the
last one to two years that they woke up
at five o'clock in the morning to get
them from the smaller
you have to deal with the reality of the
situation dwelling and pondering and
Brian doesn't do [ __ ] you cry you're
just gonna lose and I'm bad news about
complaining and crying nobody gives a
[ __ ]
nobody's gonna feel sorry for you
who's gonna feel sorry for you you I'll
tell you who's gonna feel sorry for you
oh oh you don't feel sorry for you your
other enabling using Slayers around you
it's just one [ __ ] losing circle
either you're hanging out with people
that are dragging you down or you're
hanging out with people that are lifting
you up and I promise you this every
winner in your life has zero sympathy
for you don't you just walk away I just
think that people are scared to fail in
front of other people
my friends I'm telling you something
right now I'm desperately excited to
fail in front of you because I don't
really give a [ __ ] what you think B I'm
going to learn from it and see battle
scars are attractive
speed is four billion times more
important than perfection the amount of
you that are crippled by getting [ __ ]
right instead of getting [ __ ] done is
insane we're living in a world where so
much more opportunity this internet
thing created way more opportunity for
all of us way more right I don't give a
[ __ ] if you think I'm the greatest and
[ __ ] the Messiah or if you think I'm
a piece of [ __ ] con artist I'll see you
in 2020 2030 2040 I'll see you I'll
[ __ ] see you please take a step back
and think about how awesome is actually
what you gonna do if you live you know
being successful takes several different
variables
I think self-awareness is number one if
you don't know yourself and you don't
know what you're good at you've got no
shot because you're gonna be spinning
your wheels like are you willing to be
super honest with yourself
when nobody's watching we all know who
we are sometimes we don't like that what
are you actually good at what do you
like doing because the opportunities are
endless the problem is we are scared to
do different things because the
fundamental core reality is we worry
about what other people think we worry
about getting judged
if we fail like if you're not your
number one fan you've lost cuz the
market is really good at tearing you
down every day 24/7 365 I will remind
you that life is phenomenal
that nobody gives a [ __ ] so the
government or your mommy's not going to
help you you've got to do it on your
[ __ ] but it's never been better we've
got a bigger chance than ever we can do
our thing we are strong as [ __ ] we're
really [ __ ] strong we're just being
sold that we're not cuz there's a lot of
money in telling us that we're not
pretty enough thin enough smart enough
good enough [ __ ] that I want to tell you
you're the [ __ ] Basco do [ __ ]
I just want it so bad for you I want it
bad for you I believe that you can and
by the way not I'm not like anybody can
do it like something you suck something
you don't have the skills why do you
think I talk about self-awareness I just
want you to try hard at the thing that
you may naturally be best at because
that's where everybody finds their
moment how much more motivation to
[ __ ] need like we live one life it
goes fast it's like goes fast probably
so many the reasons that you things are
happening for a lot of people is they're
confused they don't know what they want
they want a thousand things they're just
confused
stop being confused figure out what you
want reverse-engineer it and get it
the biggest poison in us is regret
poison
everybody here is already sitting with
two three four things they can think of
very quickly that they regret right now
already and right now you feel okay
because you got a lot of life to go but
if you spend time with people in their
80s and 90s the thing that you will
absolutely teach you if you really dig
is regret [ __ ] sucks when you're
super threat in a man's eyes
it's [ __ ] painful because you have
can't do [ __ ] about it when you're 90
and you're not mobile and you're tired
and it's over you can't do it you can't
do it you can't build that company you
wanted you can't spend that time with
your kid
it's regret and it [ __ ] drive this
[ __ ] up what would you do if you could
just do it all the time the only
decision that needs to be made is the
one that you will regret the least when
you're 90 all my advice is only for the
complainers this is only for the
complainers I'm not mad at you if you
play matted I don't want that mad at you
if you watch [ __ ] lost I'm not mad at
you if you watch complete seasons of
house of cards I'm not mad at you if you
play Call of Duty all day I'm not of you
if you're doing that and you're baffled
and complaining why you're not making
more money then why you're not living
your dreams gotta have a dream but
you've got to be practical the world
isn't what mommy and daddy told you the
world is exactly going to be what it's
going to be with or without the way you
thought it was going to be a ton of [ __ ]
is gonna change the world changes every
goddamn day it's equally [ __ ] pushing
it as it's very impatient and if you
push from those two extremes you [ __ ]
make sure everybody's don't want
actually or any other that's why the
people that pushed from both extremes
win yeah that's why there's so few
people that
like I have a dirty little secret for
you doing the right thing is always the
like thing like it has a funny like call
it [ __ ] karma call it whatever the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] you want doing the right
thing is the right thing the work trumps
everything it's the one non-debatable in
debate talent debate luck to make a
circumstance can't debate if somebody's
putting in the work not subjective
[ __ ] either put in the 15 16 18
hours of work that gives you the best
position to succeed in what you're
trying to achieve or you don't I just
don't get the mentality of being head
down sad on a Monday morning and a lot
of people need to hear one of two things
today which is this is the greatest era
to ever be alive and be an entrepreneur
executive if you want it and stop
complaining and dwelling cuz nobody
gives up
thank you feeling good productive 24/7
365 so that's it couldn't have gotten
better for me having somebody out of the
blue make an incredible piece of content
to wrap up what this is really about
which is as much about you guys as it is
me this community the comments section
watching what's happening in the
comments section I just love it and so I
just want to say thank you please
subscribe please pass this on to
somebody that needs to be part of this
journey this would be the time and I'll
see you tomorrow is a grinder of week
Chicago more filming in LA it's going to
be good stuff I think you'll enjoy it
see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
take a look around me taking pain